va parler de l'autre les gens de la
télévision française michel drucker qui
a fait des révélations étonnantes sur
son avenir à la france télévisions à 60
et la cage sera pas dire son âge normal
8 ans mais il est très pointu des 180
points de l'éternel
non évidemment que ça ils sont 16 75 74
il a 52 ans c'est toujours pas s'il aura
du travail en septembre
et regardez ce qu'a dit michel drucker
alors vous michel l'année prochaine aux
dates sur france 2 je sais pas comment
ça se fait bam à chaque année je voulais
qu'on me prend pas c'est qu'on a nommé
le viseur vous savez pas si vous faites
vivement dimanche à lundi prochain
mais officiellement puisque tous les
combats vente france 2 arrive à terme
poser le zombie l'imaginé bien puisque
tout ce qui s'est passé
tous les contrats qui se terminait en
avril en tout cas vous serez vous à bord
vous ça alors je le dis pour vous serez
actionnant mais j'ai peut-être venir sur
ces 8 à ça ça serait bien vous avez
produit
karim est issu je suis viré vous trouver
du boulot badauds cas il a dit va
peut-être venir sur ces mythes c'est
pour ça que ce week end j'ai reçu plein
de sms
abbas avait pas vu l'interview de
lockheed ya michel drucker sur ces huit
ça serait top ça serait top ce serait
top
il arrive à paris il a quand même signé
40 émissions de toute façon ça la saison
prochaine pas partir en plus ils
achetèrent spectacle de très grande
qualité puisqu'il remonte sur scène et
il a 77 ans peut le dire parce qu'il est
superbe et en plus il sans merci voilà
kevin tu es bien monsieur drucker c'est
vrai un temps vont de 25 ans il est
michel drucker vous madame nationale
j'adore michel mais chaque année la même
saison
ah oui une chose bah oui bah oui merci
vrai évidemment le garder pour peu que